que jean benoit harel et président de
l'association pour la messe j'en veux
douar el bonjour merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france pour commencer
peut-être votre réaction à cette
décision du conseil d'état on imagine
vous êtes soulagé ouais effectivement
nous on est assez content de cette
décision du conseil d'état qu'on a ce
matin vers 10h30
on avait déposé ce référé vendredi suite
à l'annoncé du premier ministre de
conserver cette limitation à 30
personnes
alors que les cultes et devait donc la
seule le seul endroit où il y avait une
restriction en valeur absolue et non pas
en proportion est au bout ce coup voilà
ce qu'on demandait c'était une règle
intelligente applicable adapté et le
concept a donc est allés dans notre sens
puisqu'il à s'occuper gouvernement et
lui a demandé de revoir cette limitation
de manière proportionnée au lieu de
rassemblement alors justement
concrètement qu'est-ce qui peut être
appliqué aujourd'hui qu'est ce que vous
demandez comme le protocole dans les
églises les évêques ont demandé une
jauge de 30% en fonction de la taille
évidemment une petite chapelle
c'est dit
d'une grande église comme par exemple à
saint sulpice nous voilà nous ce qu'on
demande c'est une mesure intelligente
adapté et on soutient évidemment les
évêques dans leur demande de 30 % de
taux de remplissage des églises vous
parliez des évêques la jauge à 30
personnes
elle est très mal passée 1 et on a pu
l'observer c'est assez rare notamment
sur les réseaux sociaux des évêques ou
goût des prêtres qui se sont rebellés en
disant clairement qu'ils n'accueillent
qu'ils accueilleraient tout le monde
comment vous expliquez cette grogne
finalement assez inhabituel chez des
hommes d'église
alors effectivement comme vous livre cd
c'est inhabituel mais en fait quand la
règle est absurde
les compliquer d'accepter cette règle
qui plus est quand elle est absolument
inapplicable
effectivement personnellement je suis à
la messe ce matin à paris les gestes
barrières étaient respectées la
distanciation social le geste le mas les
les
le masque le gel hydro alcoolique mais
mais évidemment il y avait plus de
personnes
plus de 30 personnes dans l'église juste
et une grande église il y avait pas de
raison et donc là un moment plus que la
règle et d'absurde et ben les jeunes et
cons
estimé qu'elle était inapplicable donc
il fallait appliquer une règle
intelligente et donc on demandait
respect d'un protocole sanitaire
à l'intérieur de ces églises mais pas la
restriction de 30 personnes était
inapplicable parce qu'il ya les mieux
pourtant une explication du ministère de
l'intérieur
il a jugé qu'il n'était pas pertinent de
comparer la situation des commerces par
exemple et celle des lieux de culte
selon lui et selon sa représentante je
vais citer dans un magasin les gens
passent ne se parlent pas ne restent pas
assis les uns à côté des autres
comment est-ce que vous recevez
comprenez cette explication alors de la
première chose c'est que la liberté du
commerce et d'industrie n'est pas à
liberté de culte
il a été tout est une liberté
fondamentale qui est inscrit dans de
nombreux textes la constitution la
déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen les textes internationaux
vous êtes une liberté fondamentale est
le président dans son ordonnance la haye
l'a explicitement dit en disant qu'elle
n'était pas comparable aux autres aux
autres activités et donc c'est là à ce
moment là que c'est c'est étonnant c'est
à dire que dans les magasins on peut
complètement se croiser dans les rayons
voilà on est aux bonnes et parfois
serrés alors al'inverse dans les églises
il ya de la place
on n'est pas si loin les uns des autres
avec un masque avec du gel hydro
alcoolique avec la distanciation sociale
et donc en où il est
probablement moins facile d'attraper le
virus dans les églises où on est
complètement éloignées et même si on est
assis plus longtemps que d'être un
commerce dans moi on ne touche pas les
livres les chaussures voilà on reste à
notre place en ce sens sans rien toucher
alors que ce n'est pas le cas dans les
commerces est-ce que plus généralement
vous avez le sentiment qu'il ya une
détérioration des relations entre les
croyants et et le gouvernement
aujourd'hui
alors ça c'est déjà un mois que nous
avec l'association pour la messe de mon
lancer notre édition d'hier que nous
avons refait des référé devant le
conseil d'état devant soutenu les
rassemblements effectivement il ya une
vraie méfiance
je pense entre les catholiques et le
gouvernement 2 par le mépris
cas le gouvernement veut en tout cas que
donne à voir le gouvernement envers
envers les catholiques pour nous
évidemment l'homme a uniquement physique
n'est pas qu'un être biologique et il ya
aussi une dimension et spirituelle
dimension sociale une dimension
psychologique on parle beaucoup des
dépressions la turquie augmenté pendant
ce confinement
et donc voilà les cultes et complètement
occulté son mauvais jeu de mots par par
le gouvernement il n'y a aucun mot les
seuls mots ou phrases à l'intention des
des catholiques sont désagréables comme
monsieur darmanin qui avaient dit qu'ils
allaient verbaliser les catholiques qui
parce c'est qu'ils participaient au
rassemblement
donc voilà les évêques continue à
vouloir un véritable dialogue
mais pour l'instant on a l'impression
que le gouvernement ne souhaite pas ce
dialogue et souhaite plutôt imposer une
discussion qui viendra au plus tôt
qu'une concertation
les voilà les gens peuvent apporter leur
leurs solutions les réconforter des
solutions et on souhaite maintenant que
le gouvernement entende ses solutions et
arrête de bafouer la liberté de culte
merci beaucoup jean-benoît à rennes je
rappelle que vous êtes président de
l'association pour la baisse